this story really upset me pretty deeply
police at UC Berkeley were filmed
ticketing and taking earned money from a
Hispanic immigrant hot dog vendor who
didn't have a permit for selling hot
dogs at UC Berkeley this was filmed by
Martin Flores and the picture here is
from Martin Flores his facebook account
and I'm gonna play the video for you if
Martin Flores observing UC Berkeley put
police ticketing this guy who in the
midst of total chaos on the UC Berkeley
campus is selling some hotdogs
take a listen take a look at this this
is are you gonna take it
ardan money people could drink on campus
on football games and no tickets but a
hard-working man selling hotdogs earning
a living get their money taken away an
order no it's not like I see people
drinking in public on campus who are did
not run or eat fallish you go down the
street you all I'm telling you right now
slow down while turned your feet to your
left and you'll see drinking in public
but a hard-working man gets his money
taken away and a ticket that's not right
Betty right man Danny right order for
the few Betty right man Betty right
thank you
nice work yeah
protected the public that are you I am
working for you not for me brother not
for me and I'm disappointed as an
alumnus appointed in this campus why you
disappoint not me because because I
stand up for somebody's working on this
incredible thinking I get it right
listen you're selling food on campus you
don't have a permit that means you might
not be served safe certified and food
handling and maybe people are gonna get
sick from your hot dogs that haven't
been kept at the right temperature there
are people everywhere underage drinking
littering some percentage you're getting
into cars and driving drunk there is a
selective nature so what police enforce
and get involved in there is some kind
of call it a police triage and you're
choosing the guy who's out working all
day working hard to make some money
providing a service people want right
he's not doing some tourist scam where
he finds your lost jewelry or whatever
million scams there are right he's set
up he'll cook you a hot dog however you
want it and you take his money and you
ticket him while there are all sorts of
other infractions that you could select
around you and maybe it's because I
identify with this guy Juan right being
an immigrant myself from from a
spanish-speaking country Argentina but
this really got to me and there is some
good news and the good news is that
Martin Flores the guy who filmed this
and put it on his Facebook page this
ticket I'm guessing was a hundred bucks
or a hundred and fifty bucks I don't
know exactly
he created a GoFundMe fundraiser which
he says he's keeping none of the money
as of this morning it had raised over
thirty two thousand dollars for one here
I again I don't know how much the ticket
was but thirty two thousand dollars will
far exceed that and Martin posted that
one has been located that they are gonna
be doing as much media coverage as they
can and he says I want to be clear that
I am getting none of this money
whatsoever
and what what are we doing this is what
society is now I don't know if it's so
much a racial component as to why he was
targeted it just seems like he's kind of
out in the open so he's an easy person
to pick out whereas maybe if you're
underage drinking you have it a little
guys so this guy yeah Ashley with you or
something like that and it takes more
investigation to figure out do you
actually drop alcohol with you or not
this guy's clearly out there selling
hotdogs they honestly understand
shutting his business down for the day
too you have to go get a permit you have
to follow the law taking his money
though really irked me because you don't
know how much money he started out with
and good luck for him trying to get that
back I mean oh yeah maybe he doesn't
have any credit cards or any other way
of paying for his ride home I find this
to be the epitome of how you know at the
macro level police are often completely
focused on all the wrong things and this
is the micro level even at this UC
Berkeley I guess it was a sporting event
that was going on or whatever there's
more important things for you to focus
on and it's absolutely ridiculous and
hey 32,000 dollars or more and I'm glad
for that I really am interlinking to the
go fund me page for one